قمة G7 هذه حرجة وتوم
فورمان سي إن إن هنا الآن لشرح لماذا توم
دعنا نسمي مجموعة السبعة لأنها
مجموعة من سبعة هؤلاء هم قادة
أكبر اقتصاد في العالم
ألمانيا كندا والمملكة المتحدة والولايات المتحدة
وفرنسا
وإيطاليا واليابان كما كانت.  لم تكن مجموعة الثماني
منذ فترة طويلة رهيبة حتى
تم طرد روسيا من المجموعة
إذا نظرت إلى
انهيار مجموعة الثماني لما حدث ثم في عام
غزت روسيا شبه جزيرة القرم وكان ذلك كافياً
لهذه الدول الأخرى لتقول إننا
لا نريدك حقًا أن تكون جزءًا  بعد
ذلك ، خرجت روسيا من الباب هناك
وكانت تلك إحدى المشكلات بالنسبة لهم ،
ثم عُرفت باسم مجموعة المكتبة
في السبعينيات عندما ظهرت لأول مرة
وتم استدعاء مجموعة المكتبة ذلك
لأنهم بدأوا في
مكتبة  البيت الأبيض ، فما
الذي يفعلونه جيدًا حقًا ، وصفه فيل
قليلاً منه منذ لحظة ،
لقد اعتبروا هذه القضايا الكبيرة العظيمة
تعني مرة واحدة في العام
أنهم ينسقون السياسة قائلين انظر إذا كان
لدينا جميعًا نية مشتركة  الباقي في الديمقراطية
اقتصاديات العمل ،
قد لا تكون العدالة في المحاكم مثالية ولكن يمكننا
مساعدة بعضنا البعض ،
لذلك عندما نتعامل مع تغير المناخ أو
التطعيمات العالمية
أو ربما حتى الأمن السيبراني في عصر
توجد فيه دول مثل
روسيا ، إيران ، الصين ، كوريا الشمالية ، مما يسمح
للأشخاص  لمهاجمة أنظمة الكمبيوتر ،
نعم ، يمكن أن تعمل مجموعة الثماني معًا وتكون لها
عواقب عالمية.